is SpongeBob SquarePant secretly dishing
up adult content to your children there
once was a man from
Nantucket sorry wrong one there once was
a girl from Nantucket not that chant oh
are these so-called harmless dirty jokes
and cartoons just innocent humor for
adults or is there something more
Sinister going
on me here we're like your biggest fans
good job I love
could it be that some of Hollywood's
animators adults are purposely slipping
some of these perverse ideas into kids
cartoons that your kids are watching and
he said well you've got all these guys
who were kind of nerds in school weren't
really social and then all of a sudden
they they get this skill they learned
how to draw really well then they're
handed millions of dollars and you're
out there in in Los Angeles and they get
themselves in a lot of trouble and
they're you know partying and doing
whatever and they're putting all those
adult jokes in there cuz they think it's
funny if that's the case then this isn't
just some innocent joke serious we've
got to investigate this SpongeBob square
pens uh one of the best known kids
cartoons out there kids cartoons you you
mentioned to me earlier that maybe maybe
more adults watch it than kids
apparently most of the viewers of
SpongeBob today are adults not even kids
anymore but it's supposed to be a kid
show it's aired still on Nickelodeon as
a kid show um and uh you know it's
interesting a couple years ago we made a
video about Nickelodeon exposing some of
the dark stuff in there and uh I don't
know if she's still there but sarami was
like the head of Viacom and I was
overlooking Nickelodeon and she was like
yeah the SpongeBob is the essence of
what we really stand for finally I
couldn't speak to you today without
mentioning our friend SpongeBob
SquarePants believe it or not SpongeBob
marks its 10th anniversary in 2009 and
we do in fact live in a SpongeBob world
because our beloved sponge does capture
the essence of what our brand really
stands for have you guys ever seen those
adult jokes hidden adult jokes in
SpongeBob and other cartoons there's a
lot of references between him and his
buddy Patrick and also like homosexual
references and yeah sometimes I look at
it I'm like man is my mind actually not
that Pure or are they being that obvious
about it yeah I think they're being that
obvious I mean you've got a lot of
adults that are making that you know and
these guys
um from what I was explained um Rico
Hill used to work on this uh show or he
part of the team that would for
Nickelodeon yeah so I asked him that one
time like said hey what's why are these
things so and he said well you've got
all these guys who were kind of nerds in
school weren't really social and then
all of a sudden they they get this skill
they learned how to draw really well
then they're handed millions of dollars
and you're out there in in Los Angeles
and they get themselves in a lot of
trouble and they're you know partying
and doing whatever and they're putting
all those adult jokes in there because
they think it's funny and it just go
flies by the radar a lot of times well
does it is the question does it really
fly by the radar of kids right like the
kids really not see this kind of stuff I
don't know I mean yeah it depends on I'm
sure the kids' age nowadays it's like
what we consider to be like kosher is
probably really boring stuff the kids
don't watch I mean there's there's a lot
of these kind of things that that kids
are getting exposed to that I think have
a lot of these things in them well and
and we'll take a look got a couple Clips
in a second but I do think that kids are
introduced to it's a younger and younger
age and so a lot of them probably will
pick up on this and it's like this
little extra seed that's being planted
in their brains and if they don't pick
up on this it's I guarantee you it's
stored somewhere that in future years
they're like oh yeah you know like
there's somehow the brain's making these
connections and I I don't think it's for
no reason so have you guys heard of rock
Rats You guys heard of that yeah this
show is popular when I was a kid and and
uh yeah so this is Nickelodeon I I
watched this as a kid too and I remember
I even went to the movie theater because
I had a Rugrats Movie out and stuff but
I want to look a couple things here uh
regarding
relationships and and dude is pretty
well let's take a look he's not much of
a pirate but I like his booty wooo and
my personal favorite lonely space
Vixens that's for after do you go to bed
an adult magazine what's in there little
toys no candy no a brother new car no
it's way better than all those things
number two Angelica messes with Innocent
art who cares about good I'm going to be
the bestest mhm we'll just see about
that both Angelica and Susie want to be
the best preschool student in the class
they constantly compete and even
sabotage each other to get ahead when
Susie draws a nice picture of her
teacher and Angelica decides to
vandalize it she draws two round circles
around the eyes and adds a long cylinder
over the nose although Angelica might
have been trying to draw a pair of funny
glasses the older audiences will have
trouble seeing anything other than male
anatomy you wrecked it I didn't mean to
since the drawing is only on screen for
a couple of seconds this joke likely
went way over our heads as kids but now
that we're older there's no way we can
unsee what Angelica Drew Angelica I will
give you five more minutes to cut that
out
what that's l i mean there's literally
like twice there's a there's a magazine
there's a DVD in there yeah I mean he's
like and this is lonely space victims
but that's for after you go to bed and
it's like hidden in the corner it's like
a half naked alien woman yeah and you
see a woman with a pair of bunny ears on
yeah yeah and then they're like
referencing to his booty and yeah yeah
and and the way that Rico kind of
explained this is you you have adults
that are putting adult you know humor
into these things as a kid you you might
not pick up on that but I'm sure it's
registering in your brain so down the
road those little seeds get watered
wasn't it wasn't there like a cartoon or
something that you mentioned that where
there was an adult joke and you
remembered it as a kid yeah uh was was
it maybe SpongeBob that we were talking
about one of that or something from
Cartoon Network when when when when I
remember cartoons actually start stting
to be vulgar was Ren and Stampy you
remember those that was kind of like the
first time that that they they would you
know have their body parts shown or or
whatever you know like their buns like
they'd pull off their pants Nickelodeon
as well yeah and and and that was the
first time I think that parents were
just like what is this nonsense you know
before it was it was just kind of
violence in the in the cartoon but this
kind of added a whole another grotesque
level mhm I never watched any of those
kinds of cartoon is I was never like a
Rugrats person or Reen Stimpy was more
like Animaniacs and Batman and that kind
of stuff mhm but I know that it it goes
pretty far and wide like the movie Cars
which you would think pretty innocuous
yeah when the two little two little
things flash their headlights cple twins
flashing you understand what that
metaphor
is we're like your biggest fans get out
I
love we love you lightning I don't know
that all the kids are picking up on that
but you know adults probably for sure so
yeah it gets it gets uh it's engraved in
there I mean I I think probably what you
were referencing to is a cartoon that I
used to watch uh Dexter's Laboratory we
got a clip on that too yeah that was
that the clip that I'm going to show was
that the one you remember maybe you
think so I got that from you I think
yeah I I mentioned it earlier okay we'll
look at that in just a second but let's
look at Spongebob now number 18 duy the
Unfaithful ghost after the Flying
Dutchman severely damages his ship the
ghost decides to move in with SpongeBob
but the change of scenery causes the
Spectre to start losing his spooky Mojo
during a particularly low point the
Flying Dutchman stops caring about
hygiene and hits on a Lady Fish but she
hesitates to accept his advances when
she notices a small but vital detail
about the ghost you like ponies I like
ponies is that a wedding
ring oh this olds nothing the
implication that the Flying Dutchman was
ready to cheat on his wife made for a
pretty mature gag if SpongeBob hadn't
kicked the lady fish out the ghost might
have ended up in the dogghouse with his
wife for eternity all righty boys part's
over time to scoot
honey I mean multiple things here going
on that I think are planting seeds you
know kids are always exposed to this
idea of ghosts I mean there's been a lot
of like ghosty type of things so to me
that's giving the wrong perspective of
of the state of the Dead yeah but yeah
you're you're you're kind of like making
fun of marriages and stuff like that so
like you know we know as Society we have
a hard time you know keeping the
marriage wholesome and and together and
was were these things kind of
contributing to planting seeds in
people's mind
just degrading marriage to like whatever
if I don't want it I'll just throw it
out you could have left that scene out I
mean just a few seconds of not including
a wedding ring and just moving on with
the story right that one's easily picked
up by kids it's not so subtle yeah you
know it's pretty obvious it's just a
little dig on like marriage doesn't
really mean anything yeah yeah and it's
so and if you don't want to chea in your
spouse it's okay then also it's not like
the ring wasn't very obvious it was
super obvious and then was like stuck on
SpongeBob's nose it's like I want you to
see this yeah you notice his clothing
and everything was see-through the ring
was not yeah think that's interesting Y
and also then the girl who seems to be
innocent in this case because she's
pointing out that he has a ring like
what are you doing she gets kicked out
of the house but he gets to stay like
what interesting so she's the bad person
and he's
not all right so um I got I I've got a
couple of Bible verses about this
because the Bible's pretty clear Exodus
20:4 14 is one of The Commandments you
shall not commit adultery but then Jesus
goes into this a little more in Matthew
27-28 you have heard that it was said to
those of old you shall not commit
adultery but I say to you that whoever
looks at a woman to Lust For Her has
already committed adultery with her in
his heart so so I mean what the what the
ghost did with the fish it's adultery
what that lady did in the beginning in
Rugrats he's like oh he's got to nice
booty like what are you doing you're
lusting after another person you know
openly publicly and you know Ruger hats
is watched by very young children just
put in their brain like oh I can go
flirt and like call out someone's booty
you know I I like that Jesus brought
this up because in this day and age um
you know it's always been like kind of
Slam on the woman and uh you know he's
he's addressing the men in this and the
woman that was caught in adultery I mean
where's the dude that she was with yeah
he drug out there you know it's like
it's kind of just like really speaks to
at that time you know they were always
thinking that women's the problem and um
you know he hit the nail in the head
it's like no I'm going talk to you boys
yeah I agree all right so here comes
Dexter's Laboratories a show on Cartoon
Network okay Dexter you can answer the
door for your
girlfriend I do not know what you are
talking about but as long as I am here I
might as well okay Dexter T
[Music]
cool
CIA how's my little guy this
evening Lisa thanks for coming over hun
there's food in the kitchen and we left
the number where you can reach us be
good kid
ah
yes oh yeah sure I saw your game today
you were great hello Jeff Lisa are you
there Lisa Dexter telephone line
disconnected ready for redial and voice
augmentation
[Music]
good hello Lisa what happened oh I guess
we just got cut off but I wanted to call
you back and tell you that you have got
coties and I'm in love with Tex F hello
Lisa hey what is this hello that's it
I'm coming over now for fish
[Music]
too hello Jeff Jeff what happened oh I
guess we just got cut off but I wanted
to call you back and tell you that you
have got cuties and I'm in love with
with my f ball Jeff Jeff are you
there mission
accomplished what do you guys think
about
that fact that he's meddling in their
relationship right yeah pretty dishonest
yeah he's like lying he's just setting
it up he's the main character of the
show too yeah yeah so the Bible's got
something to say about this 1
Corinthians 13: 4-7 love suffers long
and is kind love does not envy love does
not parade itself is not puffed up does
not behave rudely does not seek its own
is not provoked thinks not evil does not
rejoice in iniquity but rejoices in the
truth Bears all things believes all
things hopes all things endures all
things that's God's love that's biblical
love which is really um thinking of
somebody else and you know being others
focused and here here we see in this
particular example here he's only
thinking about himself he doesn't care
who he hurts just to get what he wants
yeah I mean he obviously caused the girl
pain
and you caused him anger and stuff so
you know in in little subtle ways I mean
think of our lives are just built on
these experiences of things that we see
and learn from and we're a bunch of
monkey see monkey do so yeah a clip like
that can easily plant some seeds in
people's minds M that's your problem
no yeah it's interesting because I I I
grew up on Nickelodeon my parents my dad
would always buy new TVs and like every
couple years and the the old TVs that we
just put in our bedrooms which I think
is not a good idea don't never do that
but we were just I was binge watching
the codeon and then when I was old
enough I was binge watching MTV and so I
I watched this like all the time I got
out of school I watch TV till like going
to bed every single day and and I can
guarantee you I know for a fact this is
not the only oneoff time that this shows
up this kind of theme shows up in in a
kids show it's always like that it's
always about me myself what can I get
out of it what can I do um it's never
about let's just be loving and kind to
somebody else it's always like breaking
the rules and those kind of things
rebell against your parents you know so
so yeah if we you know raise our kids
with the Bible this is what you get if
you raise your kids on TV that's got to
be the result you know and the reality
is how many parents are actually sitting
there and probably watching this with
their children or beforehand making sure
you know you know and and and a lot of
times you're going to just like turn it
on and go do something else so this kind
of stuff gets like the programs inside
of your kids' Minds so next up we got
Teen Titans Keith this might have been
more up your alley this is from DC
Comics originally um but yeah it was was
aired on on Cartoon Network number 10
Starfire and Robin Teen Titans franchise
in most if not all of the Teen Titans
media out there Robin and Starfire meet
under less than ideal circumstances
that's probably what brings them so
close in the first place there now maybe
we can
be if you wish not to be destroyed you
will leave me
alone okay so first I'm forcing a kiss
on you and then I'm going to shout in
your face that was weird it was super
weird it was like super aggressive and
again this is the picture of love love
that kids get but the Bible says in
Colossians 31 12-13 therefore as the
elect of God holy and beloved put on
Tender Mercies kindness humility
meekness longsuffering bearing with one
another and forgiving one another if
anyone is a complaint against another
even as Christ forgave so you also must
do so do you guys think that this is
showing Christlike
love no and you know you have a one
pound problem if you're if you're in a
broken home mhm you know because you're
not you're not seeing that that picture
played out and so you're just getting it
from all ends mhm and you you wonder why
you know people struggle in in
relationships I was just reading the
other day and I think um guys that are
under 30 like six out of 10 of them are
single wow under 30 yeah H wow
generation ever been more single than
compared to any other that's that's a
fact I think there's a lot of artificial
love
happening yeah so maybe they're getting
pacified rather than yeah other ways
yeah but but you you know if if your
relationships look like this or they're
they're not looking right at home then
you're going to look for something else
right and you know we'll talk about that
on another show that I'm working on but
I think they tend to be more inward
inward you start to think more like well
it's not working with other people so
might as well just get what I want out
of it m yeah I really think that Satan's
got something for every generation and
he's just starting to feed them from
Young and if the Bible says um you know
raise up a child in the way of the Lord
and He will not depart from depart from
it then you know Satan is trying to do
the same thing he's like if I just get
them young you know then then then
they're most likely going to stay in
this Direction obviously God's Mercy is
greater his love is greater but but
really if you're set off on the wrong
foot from a young age man it makes it
that much harder yeah but you think of
the words of Jesus too and how powerful
it is when he says You must be born
again yes you know yes it's like you
need to you need to start over young so
they can be transformed and shaped from
a a new start a new beginning MH you
guys heard of uh Hey Arnold you guys
ever watched that no you have not a lot
of the a lot these kind of like
Nickelodeon shows there's Nickelodeon
again yeah Nickelodeon yeah I missed a
lot of these wow yeah so I remember this
specifically and that's why I picked it
out I watched this growing up um it's
about this kid on the right and this I
think his name is Olga Arnold is on the
right anyway so so Arnold is always
bullied by Olga Olga is like this
masculine kind of girl who's always
being mean but secretly deep down she
actually really likes Arnold she just
never never tells him in this case she
actually tells him let's take a look at
what's happening maybe I don't hate you
as much as I thought okay I guess maybe
I I even kind of like you a little I
guess you might even kind of say that I
like you a lot you do you did this for
me that's right hair boy I mean crimey
what El are you supposed to do when
someone you love is in trouble love you
heard me pal I love you love you who
else do you think has been stalking you
night and day building shrines to you in
a closet filling volumes of books with
poems about you I love you Arnold I've
always loved you ever since I just laid
eyes on your stupid football head and
from that moment in every moment since
I've lived and breathed for you dreamed
of the moment I could finally tell you
my secret feelings and could grab you
and kiss you and oh come here you big
[Music]
lug I'm confused did you just say you
love me what are you de Arnold not now
not now who the oh Arnold just told me I
I I need to think yes I suppose you'll
have to do the thinking for both of us
now
darling wa this is all happening too
fast I feel I feel dizzy I need to lie
down wonderful I'll go with you no I
think it's interesting that these few
examples that you've been showing it's
like the female is the aggressor yeah
that's true Teen Titus is the same thing
yeah yeah and they're the ones being I I
don't know how inappropriate that would
probably send off alarm Bells if the guy
was trying to constantly do that mhm
yeah I've never seen this show but I
have seen a clip where she is like
writing she has this like poem Journal
thing and there's she made this like
homemade statue of Arnold and she's like
writing him like a letter saying I will
worship you you make and she says I'm
like you make my woman my my Womanhood
tingle and there's a parrot there and
the parrot starts repeating you make my
Womanhood like tingle or something like
that like you make me want to to uh use
my Womanhood for you or something like
that like okay that's that's a step
further than just you know aggressively
kissing someone Arnold my love my sultry
pretin why must I hold you only whilst I
dream will I be forever enslaved by your
spell why must I worship you and never
ever tell oh Arnold you make my girlhood
tremble oh
you make my girlhood tremble Arnold you
make my girlhood tremble yeah I remember
from when I watched the hate Arnold she
was basically like you said worshiping
him secretly and she had like this
closet or something where she had all
these mirabilia from him she would like
secretly cut his hair so that end of
itself is problematic it's like stalker
yeah dude and then again I mean what are
kids being taught here there's multiple
issues with this one you shouldn't be
worshiping somebody else and two you
know how many how frequently teenagers
just get absolutely infatuated with
somebody else and it's just like all
reasoning goes out the door and it's
just a bunch of hormones and and it's
like yeah this is just adding to that
like oh this is totally okay you should
just give into that mhm um and then on
top of that of course the fact that she
is forcefully kissing him I mean how
many kids are sleeping around at like 12
right and it's they're just like
oh yeah of course I can force myself
upon somebody and like you were saying
well it's a female so maybe it's a way
to like soften the image of it but it's
still wrong and boys watch this show too
and they might take this as like oh this
this is how you do you just walk up to
somebody and smooch them on the lips
even if they don't want it you just keep
going like what it's just so bizarre and
and then on top of that obviously just
like in Teen Titans she was just
straight up mean it's like a mixture of
love and just cruelty
yeah it's not it's not a clear picture
of like what you would think is a
Biblical way to love somebody right you
know help them be kind to them patient
with them and exactly and that's what
Philippians 2 3 and 4 says as well let
nothing be done through selfish ambition
she was pretty selfish in this regard or
conceit but in loneliness of Mind Let
each esteem others better than himself
let each of you look out not only for
his own interests but also for the
interests of others so this is pretty
much the opposite of what was happening
here all right so let's go back to
SpongeBob here's a couple bonus Clips uh
yikes this one's pretty obvious to us um
and again I I don't believe that this is
just adult jokes for like a good laugh I
really think this this is planting a
seed even if the kids don't get it yet I
really think this is something that um
you know is is doing something so let's
take look number 19 exploding wiener
okay that didn't work at all it only
seemed to increase their appetite for
wieners once SpongeBob discovers that
leftover Patty meat can be shaped into
wieners Mr Krab sees a golden new
business opportunity the crustacean
jacks up the price for this new product
and becomes so obsessed that he stops
selling his signature burger while the
intense focus on crusty dogs leads to a
lot of talk about wieners the one that
sounds dirtiest comes from Squidward
right something that would make Mr Krab
whole wiener thing blow right up in his
face the cashier's bitter request sounds
like a euphemism for another activity
entirely when Squidward's line is
coupled with the imagery of the Crusty
dog exploding over fish you get one
dirty joke um
wow I we actually used this in the video
we made about Nickelodeon years ago and
there's actually another clip where
where SpongeBob respond so he's like
yeah winter thing blow up in his face
and then SpongeBob is like like yeah
blow up up so I mean yeah they keep
referencing it I mean even the drawings
are somewhat inappropriate you know it's
like yeah there's there's a lot of
little thing hidden things in here that
I think are just yeah okay so uh this is
actually a reference or a clip a cut out
from the episode about nickon that we
did Link in the description if you want
to watch the whole episode especially if
you're a parent I telling you really
should watch this it exposes Nickelodeon
on a larger scale but let's look at this
it makes one wonder why a TV channel
that tries to portray itself as
kid-friendly has such adult and occult
themes in their Flagship show if
SpongeBob is the essence of what
Nickelodeon really stands for are the
other shows any different unfortunately
not well if if they got to if they got
to make a close-up shot of a Popsicle or
a lollipop that looks like SpongeBob and
then later
reveal that oh wait it's not what we
were thinking is because they wanted us
to think that yeah they want us to
somehow have think of it in in the in
the wrong way and and when kids watch
this stuff okay biologically you know
when we see something that we shouldn't
it messes with us right that's how works
or even just seeing decent images even
if it's not full nudity but if kids are
this is like the kids version mhm it's
totally going to lead up to the bigger
stuff to the bigger things that that's
why we see that kids are getting exposed
at a younger age right because kids are
seeing it here in an innocent way but
they're like okay well C I like the
feeling that cartoons gave me but like
it's not giving me enough so they go
like searching I guess more Expos Expos
until it's like you know yeah you're
building on a foundation and philosophy
I I remember being very struck by seeing
a movie poster be because I would when I
would speak to audiences I would tell
them you know a lot of cartoons are
based on this Foundation of no rules no
rules no rules no rules you know get rid
of rules right and then one day I came
across a movie poster for one of the 50
Shades of Gray films and it said no more
rules and I was like well that's how far
this goes MH you know it it it doesn't
just stop when they're young it carries
into adulthood and then that really you
know based on the themes of that movie
starts really messing with um
their relationship with with human other
human beings and with God because God
designed that marriage covenant to be a
a picture of himself in his church if
you like what they say in the cartoons
with no more rules and that theme is
transferred over to more mature
content why wouldn't you like the mature
content right yeah I also really wonder
how much this eventually either leads to
or like how if if this is like
satisfying because we earlier we
were um I was showing Felipe I was
really put off by this and really
shocked you know we have Tu budy which
is a plugin so that we can figure out
like what tags to use for our our videos
and stuff like that and I actually went
to this original Nickelodeon video that
we did and I remember that at the time I
made the title Nickelodeon is setting
selling kids and later on it was changed
to something else but I'm assuming that
that history Tu bu recognized and I went
to the tags and I was like oh wonder
what two bu says how we are being found
you know through what tags and all when
I clicked on it it's like two bu
suggesting these tags will help you be
found right it was like 50 to 100 tags
that all had to do with kids meaning
people were searching on YouTube child
50 to 100 different variations of it to
try to find that for children or with
children with children yeah that kids
the children can watch and so I'm just
thinking like why would Tu buddy make
the connection between this video and
and it shows the amount of of searches
that happened thousands it was thousands
well and then why do those why do those
Search terms bring
results I think that's a bigger question
yeah you know yeah I think if you if you
really have a distorted view of Love cuz
that's really what's going on right if
you really truly love your neighbor or
other children You' want to protect them
you don't want to take advantage of them
and so I think this is systemic of a
much larger and
longer like twisting of what love really
is MHM yeah and so again like if we
believe that this could put is is
prepping kids for at a way too early age
right and then like maybe later on as
they're already having these seeds
planted them they might become
interested in we know that people who
will fall really deep into you go off to
the deep end in IT which happens very
frequently The Next Step that they're
interested in is is wild stuff
like it happens and so it's like I it's
so hard to think of an innocent kid
watching this becoming adult and doing
that but I don't think that this is not
for no reason Satan is not out there
thinking well all I want to do is just
teach him a little bit about when they
too young and that's where I'll stop
he's not going to stop like he's like
I've got you now I'm going to keep going
and push it as far as I can and so we
really have a decision to make are we
going to put them on the directory of
God and the Bible and showed them what
true love and true relationships and
true into Bible is like or we allow this
and it's starting to plant seeds toward
the other side Satan is not going to be
out outwardly obvious at first if he
wants to reach children and even adults
right you got to start with a small
things because we always uh you know
parents will have to talk with their
children hey don't act this type of
stuff or hey don't don't get into
strangers Vans or whatever but then
that's why
even with
most cases happen with someone who was
close to the child MH right so it's not
that obvious when the Predator happens
and same with with the it starts with
little things and then it increases to
the point where okay I am desensitized
to you know fullon Unity it starts with
little things like cartoons that have
inappropriate things in it yeah I can
guarantee you that that there is no out
there who's not watching zero it just
doesn't happen um and then also Anthony
ke is the the lead singer for The Red
Hot Chili Peppers I sent you a
documentary recently that kind of
exposed his journey for where why he is
dating 19-year-old girls now I mean and
he's like almost 50 something 56 54
something like that but it is messed up
dude he went to live with his dad in La
cuz he thought that was more fun and his
dad sort of feeding him and that was
time where his his dad said in an
interview it's been recorded where he's
like well I didn't want my son to be the
last of the class to end up having for
the first time I like I was I wanted to
be the first and so um he was like
teaching his son at a 12-year-old age
about and then um he I guess his dad had
a girlfriend or a woman he was
interested in that were at this
restaurant or a bar or something which
again why is this kid Anthony there 12
years old and Anthony hands his dad a
note he's like and the note said I want
to have SE with your girlfriend can I do
that and his dad's like yeah I'll set
you up now either the dad was sleeping
with miners himself for the for the
girlfriend to be the same age as Anthony
or which is more likely his girlfriend
was an adult and she had with a minor
and that yep he set it up he's like
here's the bed now look at what happened
to Anthony today he's having girlfriends
that are just just the right age right
that he can publicly parade around I
mean what's the trajectory of when you
deal with that stuff as a kid um and
then so so you know what does the Bible
say we should be like Philippians 4:8
finally Brethren whatever things are
true whatever things are noble whatever
things are just whatever things are pure
whatever things are lovely whatever
things are of good report if there's any
virtue and if there's any praiseworthy
meditate on these things this is what
we're supposed to be looking at I don't
think it helps anybody um you know a lot
of these things that don't have God in
the perspective or the
picture it's just you know humorous to
people that you know probably have no
connection to God whatsoever and so I
think you know the the more that we can
spend time really building that
relationship with God and then you know
not allowing these worldly things to
kind of come into our homes I think I
think you will you will
make your taste buds desire wholesome
things like this I think when you
constantly eat the junk food of the
world you're going to form your taste
buds for that and that's what you're
going to be drawn to so we do have to
make a decision at this point are we
going to have wholesome things in our
life or we going to have these terrible
disgusting worldly things now why does
any of this matter right I've referenced
this so many times so I won't uh
verbalize it myself let's take a look at
this clip and see
how this stuff is affecting our brain
and how it's actually changing us the
name mirror neuron comes from the fact
that they fire both when you do
something and when you watch someone
doing something even if you like don't
move a muscle basically it's as if they
mirror the neural activity of the person
actually doing the thing in other words
by beholding we become changed but we
all with unveiled face beholding as in a
mirror the glory of the Lord are being
being transformed into the same image
from glory to glory just as by the
spirit of the Lord if by beholding Jesus
we can become more like him it also
works the other way around science
confirms this biblical Doctrine so yeah
that was my voice that was a clip that I
used or made for a a video about the
Barbie movie also on her Channel if you
want to watch it we'll put a link in the
description to that too but again this
is science this is how the brain works
monkey see monkey do what do um if I do
something and you see me doing something
your brain can't register the difference
between seeing me seeing me doing it and
you doing it yourself so again when kids
watch these kind of things hey it might
actually register it might actually
plant a seed and it might actually act
in your brain as if you were doing it
yourself and that's disgusting so well
you know um I never like doing these
kind of videos that are kind of dark and
and and and just sad but there's two too
many kids out there that are watching
this and they are innocent they don't
know anything about what's going on and
you know some of the parents don't know
either like I grew up into stuff my mom
grew up as a Christian um and we weren't
Christian in our home when I was growing
up but there was many times when he she
saw me watching something and was like
hey don't watch that because that's not
good they try you know and and people
just don't always know and that's why I
want to put this information out there
not to judge anyone or any parent but to
provide a resource and to say look this
is what's going on and now they can make
a decision and prayerfully take it to
God and say Lord yeah help me to really
raise my kids in the fear of the Lord
and you know because that's what God
wants and he wants us to have a correct
portrayal of love and relationships and
marriage the way he designed it to be
and I believe Satan is using this kind
of stuff to do the opposite so let's um
let's stay close to Jesus because he's
coming soon and uh let's feed our kids
the Bible and and genuine loving good
stuff thank you guys for watching make
sure you hit like And subscribe a lot of
people watch these videos are not
subscribed but uh I think you'll like a
bunch of other videos that we've got
that are coming out soon so hit the
Subscribe button below other than that
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
we'll see you next week
[Music]
a